foreign
[Music]
the first teaser for Godzilla X Kong the
new Empire came like a bombshell
revealing footage of the new villain in
the monster sequel since he never
appeared in the comics nor in the old
movies speculations about his role
origin and power are running wild the
teaser also offers a lot of room for
assumptions about the plot of the movie
so in this video we've put together the
most relevant theories
first of all what is actually shown in
the teaser the red ape titan is seen
sitting on a throne in the hollow Earth
around him lie the bones of other Titans
his eyes glow blue like the energy of
the hollow Earth at the end of the scene
we see the skulls of Godzilla and Kong
glowing in blue and yellow light the
bones around the throne suggest that
this new Kaiju is very old and one of
the few survivors of the Greek Kaiju War
unlike Kong a gorilla the new enemy is
an orangutan as its reddish fur reveals
but now the question arises who exactly
is he since he also belongs to an ape
species we can already conclude that we
will learn more about Kong and that
Godzilla will function more as a
supporting character Kong in the new
movie through the new Kaiju we also see
a new ape species in the universe for
the first time orangutans are often
stylized in movies as the whys are
ruling Apes while gorillas tend to be
the fighters we could therefore assume
that he is some sort of alpha creature
while Kong was more of a foot soldier
during the Kaiju War many wonder why he
enters the stage at this particular time
one explanation would be the portal
through which one gets to the hollow
Earth this seems to be made of the same
energy that Godzilla uses for his Atomic
breath while Kong and the humans travel
through the portal Godzilla manages to
pierce the Earth crust with a beam and
shoot directly into the hollow Earth in
doing so he could have either destroyed
the portal which could also be used to
keep the Titans trapped beneath or could
have used this energy to awaken the new
Kong it would be possible that he senses
the fight between Godzilla and Kong and
therefore awakens as the last survivor
of the war between the Titan races he
can now set out to end it once and for
all and rule over the Earth he could be
especially powerful since the glow of
his eyes suggests that he too like
Godzilla can utilize the energy of the
hollow Earth for himself while Kong
relies solely on his muscles the new
enemy may also be the reason why Kong
and His Kind had to flee to the surface
driving them out of the hollow Earth
ages ago with the skull crawlers that we
see in the movie Skull Island he might
have tried to bound them to the island
so that they couldn't escape the
storyline might also not follow a linear
course considering how old the new Kaiju
is there is hope that we might get to
see footage from old Wars more or less
to tell a story
especially among American fans there is
another theory that holds great promise
if you look at the attitude of the Kaiju
it is very reminiscent of Thanos from
the MCU so there is also the theory that
the new Empire not only teases a movie
but a series of movies in which they
have to face this very opponent only at
the end it would be possible that he as
the former King of the hollow Earth now
sends all kinds of monsters at Godzilla
and Kong to annihilate them so we would
soon have a real monster verse taking it
to the next level we could even imagine
that we might end up with different
phases of movies this Theory would be
supported by the sheer popularity of the
last films which have grossed more than
2 billion dollars at the box office
regardless of which Theory will turn out
to be true or whether we get something
entirely different than we expect the
movie Godzilla X Kong promises a lot and
is certainly one of the most exciting
releases of 2024. as soon as we have a
first trailer we will know more and of
course you'll get to watch it right away
in our Channel as always what do you
think will happen in the movie do the
theories sound reasonable to you or do
you have totally different ideas let us
know in the comments
[Music]
thank you